hola unas noches pues varias de estas
acciones legales han sido desestimadas
en los estados en donde había pedido que
se detuviera el conteo si les han
permitido a los miembros de la campaña
del presidente de donald trump estar más
cerca de pasar de estar a 12 pies a
estar a 6 pies de distancia de donde se
están realizando estos conteos pero
hasta el momento no se ha instaurado una
gran demanda frente a un fraude
electoral como lo ha prometido el
presidente hay que asegurar también que
uno de los temas que llama la atención
frente a estas declaraciones del
secretario de estado es que no solamente
dijo esto sino que también el tratar de
impugnar los resultados electorales es
completamente apropiado ya que estos
sistemas electorales están respaldados
por la constitución y la administración
va a ser lo que sea necesario para
hacerlos respetar
diana y es que hoy también en eeuu es un
día clave para un tema que marcó la
campaña a la presidencia la corte
suprema- empezó a decidir el futuro de
obama care escuchando los argumentos de
un caso presentado por los republicanos
para buscar la inc o
inconstitucionalidad de la ley del
cuidado de salud la corte suprema- salvo
la ley en 2012 y 2015 pero ahora es la
más conservadora en 50 años con una
mayoría de seis a tres sin embargo al
menos cinco jueces del máximo tribunal
entre ellos bread camp nou y john
roberts conservadores sugirieron que no
votaran para derogarla
diana que es exactamente lo que está en
juego en estas audiencias
está en juego que cerca de 20 millones
de estadounidenses podrían perder su
cobertura en seguro médico justo en
medio de la pandemia y también muchas
personas que tienen preexistencias
médicas como cáncer o asma este no es el
primer intento como lo mencionaba del
presidente de donald trump y de los
republicanos esta es una demanda de 18
estados republicanos encabezada por
texas la gran diferencia ahora es que
está la juez barrera y de esta manera
cambiar la balanza seis conservadores
miembros del tribunal supremo- frente a
tres más liberales y se espera que la
corte suprema después de escuchar los
argumentos pueda avanzar sobre una
decisión frente a obama que muy pronto